hello everyone and welcome to round nine
of this year's data steel Masters
Edition it is World Chess Championship
Contender ding lyron versus The Local
Hero anishigiri and they will face off
in a nice ready that will transpose into
a neocatlan so not gonna spoil too much
it's a wonderful game uh you will have
to to very nice pause the video moments
let's check it out so ding with the
white pieces opens with Knight to F3 he
goes for that at the opening and D5 by
Anish we have G3 going for the king's
Indian attack Knight to F3 sorry Knight
to F6 Bishop to G2 and now Pawn to E6
with castles and the bishop to E7 the
Yugoslav variation of the king's Indian
Ponte C4 uh and now we have uh just
Castles by Anish we have Ponta B3 and
advancing the pawn all the way to D4
going into the the
neocatal in defense with E3 and now Pawn
to C5 a grabbing hold of the center we
have knighted the E5 a standard move you
will see in a Catalan occupying the E5
square with the Knight grabbing hold of
this beautiful diagonal with the bishop
and now Queen to C7 uh just uh or
getting the queen to a nice Square
attacking the Knight on E5 F4 uh ding
defends the Knight and now Knight B to
D7 Anish again puts pressure on the
Knight and now just Knights the D3
avoiding the trade and keeping the
tension on the ball we have Pawn to E5
by a niche and now at night the A3 going
for that B5 Square to chase away the
queen so A6 biting with Bishop to B2 and
now Bishop to D6 adding another Defender
to E5 and there is a game where Knight
the C2 was played but here we have G4 by
Ding and it is now as of move 13 that we
have a completely new game so is this
something that Ding came up uh with over
the board or maybe is this part of the
world championship preparation it's hard
to say but it is very unlikely that he
would um you know sort of wasted
preparation on on a tournament before
playing the world's championship match
uh so G4 and now e captures an F4 by a
niche with Pawn to G5 this being the the
true idea and here he sort of manages to
uh trick Anish Anish goes back Knights
the E8 the the cleanest way to play this
is f captures on E3 and try to go for
this sacrificial attack now if G
captures an F6 you simply recapture and
you have a lot of compensation for that
sacrifice piece the nice Bishop pair the
defended past Pawn on E3 while soon to
be past spawn and if something like H3
because the H2 Pawn is hanging as well
it's the H3 Queen E7 already with the
threat of E2 black has a lot to play for
here uh but okay being uh scared him a
little bit here with Ponte G5 and he
goes back Knight to E8 and now Knight
captures an F4 nicely recapturing here
with d captures an e3d captures and now
Bishop to E5 uh Anisha of course wants
the uh well uh eliminated the the bishop
on B2 as it's an incredibly strong piece
so Queen to C2 and now Knight to D6
getting the other Knight into the game
as well uh Rook 8 to the one by Ding and
now Rook the E8 just continuing
development and now uh what do you play
here you could go for something like
Knight to D5 it's uh it's definitely a
possibility let's say Knight and D5
attacks the queen queen goes back and
now you defend the pawn pawn to H4 and
you pretty much solve all of your
problems but maybe there's something
even better uh dingo's Knights to B1 uh
and now Pawn to A5 by Anish not allowing
any future a B for it to happen we have
pawned the A4 now completely locking up
the queen side and Bishop captures and
B2 Anish trades the bishop the Bishops
we have Queen captures on B2 and now
Knights the E5 very nicely uh then the
Knight is on a beautiful E5 Square here
Knight the C3 now going for D5 or B5
depending on what black plays and now
Bishop to G4 uh Anish develops attacking
dings rook and D1 Rook to D5 and now
Knights the F5 so here we have a very
very tricky position where uh ding has
to figure out how to go about this
position he could could go for something
like Knight to B5 uh but it's not easy
to see what the Knight will do on B5 for
the rest of the game so instead dingo's
back Rook to D2 and he offers the E3
Pawn to a niche but that's uh well
that's just easier said than done the
spawn really should not be captured and
interestingly that's exactly what a
niche does you what you should play is
go for Knight to H4 and really put
pressure on that F3 square but then each
fix it up he attacks The Rook on F1 and
now things get incredibly interesting
Knight C to D5 now attacks the queen and
forces Knight captures any on D5
otherwise you just blunder the Knight on
E3 so Knight captures on D5 Knight
captures on D5 again the queen is
hanging and queen to B8 uh Anisha
keeping hold of this diagonal you have
to
also keep defending the Knight here H3
chases away the bishop and the bishop to
E6 now and now ding plays Knight to F4 a
slight Improvement to the position would
be Queen to C3 here you have all of
these options of just re-maneuvering the
queen over to the king side but now with
this bishop Knight to F4 move he allows
a niche a very very uh cool move and
Anish goes for it he plays Bishop
captures on C4 and why not you offer two
pawns for for a piece and some activity
uh or that's uh the the best uh position
a niche had this entire game and now the
problem is you should capture but ding
doesn't because the the position isn't
all that great but upon captures Knight
captures now you will lose the exchange
as well and after something like Queen
to see three Knight captures and eat
your queen captures you're gonna play
some like Queen E5 you're gonna
centralize your queen now it's a a rook
against Knight and Bishop and also it's
a three one on the queen side once Anish
starts pushing those pawns it's not
going to be easy to stop them so it
would be black would be better here
whether it's enough for a win it depends
on whether or not a dink can defend
pretty much perfectly so instead after
Bishop to C4 ding goes for Rook F to F2
he just doubles up on the second rank as
The Rook on F1 was attacked but now
Anish just goes back Bishop to A6 and he
just snatched um upon clean so to say
because he was already up upon now he
just snatched another one he's up to
pawn so what can ding um
uh due to try and uh well make something
of the position he does have something
he has knighted the H5 now he's putting
pressure on the G7 Pawn if the knight
ever moves uh you're you're just gonna
get checkmated and also there are all
sorts of nasty ideas with sacrificing
the Knight and F6 with check and so on
so Rook the E7 uh we have rooked D5 now
attacking uh putting more pressure on
the Knight and E5 also attacking the C5
Pawn here and the queen to C7 by Anish
preparing to bring the other Rook to
help out with the defense and the attack
and now ding plays Rook the F5 and this
is where uh ding really shows that he is
not fully immersed in the game it was
still possible to maybe play it with a
with a move like Queen to C3 this puts
pressure on the C5 pawn and the ones you
defended now you go for this Knight to
F6 check and now the problem is if you
capture then you open up the G file for
the queen and uh that that's not gonna
be great but if you play King the h8
black will still always have the upper
hand point being that now after Rook
captures on E5 or let's say Rook
captures an E5 Bishop captures an A8 G
captures an F6 G captures on F6 it seems
like uh White um uh has a has a fetus
attack and black will not be able to
defend uh but it's actually the other
way around let's say Rook to G5 with
check and you no longer have to worry
about anything if King to H1 just Rogue
G3 attacks the queen threatens Rook
captures on H3 uh Black's attack is just
much faster and this F6 spawn you know
instead of helping White's attack it's
actually defending the black king so
here black would be completely winning
well see while Queen to C3 might not be
uh losing for white right away it is a
White's best chance of saving the game
however after Rook to F5 a move that
doesn't really do all that much Anish
just brings another piece into the game
and of course with uh not with Tempo but
sort of with a Tempo block because now
uh the Knight is is sufficiently
defended and he brought his last piece
into the game now ding does play Queen
to C3 but now it's different Pawn to B6
and now Knight to F6 check now the
difference is uh not only should you
capture the Knight that is the only
thing black can do so G captures on F6 G
captures an F6 and now uh there is only
one way to win the game for a niche but
feel free to pause the video and try to
figure it out while I give you a couple
of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting this
brilliancy and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it is of course
Knight the F3 Knight to F3 check and now
there is nothing more to be done here
for ding the problem is uh whatever you
do and uh hear ding captured on F3 it's
it's the best move he has the problem is
this Rook the E1 check which being
played uh which on each played and now
being defended with the bishop to F1 and
here you could play many moves many
moves are winning and like Bishop
captures and F1 is sufficient to win uh
Anish shows that he is not a butcher
that he is an artist he plays King the
h8 and he was in this position on a move
37 that the England resigned the game as
there is nothing more to be done here
The Rook is coming to G8 and that's
pretty much it basically we get to the
same position even if you just capture
an F1 you don't have to play the fancy
King to h8 you can just capture F1 and
now it's pretty much the same Rook
captures Rook captures with checking
captures and now after Queen to F4 check
as the king cannot go to the E file you
have to go to the G file and now King
the h8 it's pretty much the same thing
and that's the idea of King th8 Now The
Rook will occupy G8 and there's no way
to stop this um if you want to try
something like Rook D2 to G2 to block
the black Rook uh it doesn't work like
let's say Rook to D2 now you allow Rook
to E1 with check now the queen is in the
guardian D1 square and let's say Rook D1
with check King G2 and now it's a king
Hunter basically uh White will have to
give up a lot of material to survive
this like the king F3 Rook to F1
checking the E2 Queen to G2 check King
D3 Rook to F3 check now let's say King
E4 trying to trick uh black into
capturing the queen then white captures
the queen as well but it just Rook the
F2 a nice discovered check blocking the
Rooks attack to the queen king to D3 and
now Queen captures on H3 with check
that's pretty much it uh King C2 you
trade everything now captures captures
captures and captures and you are up to
pawns let's say H5 you're gonna uh
you're gonna win the df6 pawn as well
you're gonna be up three pawns and of
course this would be completely winning
for black uh of course both of them know
this and after King the h8 it was in
this position that dingler and resigned
the game as there is nothing more to be
done here as most of the other games are
still being in play we don't know how
Abdus will uh uh finish his game as he
he was the tournament leader going into
round nine so we'll see what this means
for the standings but I will show at
least one more game and then we are
going to discuss the full standings but
what does this mean for for ding not
only does he did he lose the game he
also dropped out of the 2800 rating uh
list on the on the video on the on the
live ratings list so he's now like 27.90
something uh which doesn't mean all that
much he can still bounce back if he if
he wins a few games but it's not looking
great for the wheelchair Championship
Contender and what a tournament for a
niche not not only beating Magnus
Carlsen the world champion but also
crushing uh the dingler like this with
the black pieces uh the World Chess
Championship Contender if Nepal was in
this tournament and uh Anisha defeated
him they would just have to give up the
the classical title to a niche there
would be no other way to to resolve the
matter
but yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it very nicely done by Anish
playing some incredible chess here I
would like to thank Rob Victor David
Peter and John Noonan for a contribution
to my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
all my previous videos here thank all
for watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the Tata
steel Masters and Challengers until it
finishes so thank you all I will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day